[Musique]
une compétition de voile un peu spéciale
ce dimanche 29 octobre sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
le navigateur n'est pas sur l'eau mais
bien sur la terre ferme 13 participants
se sont inscrits pour cette course
versée parmi eux johan poulain 45 ans ce
passionné venu spécialement de vendée
pour participer à cette journée
personnellement vous prendre du plaisir
à naviguer et puis aussi à les préparer
les bateaux allaient construire au moins
40% du plaisir c'est fabriqué développer
de m'améliorer sur ce plan d'eau il
présente sa toute nouvelle formule 1 des
mers le bateau mesure entre 127 et 129
cm de long avec un demi mètre carrés de
voile celui ci donc les fabriquer en
début mars celle de cette année donc
c'est tout en carbone 1 uniquement du
carbone et donc c'est fabriqué bay
dans un moule dans lequel on applique du
tissu de la résine ont fait cuire tout
ça on fait cuire tout ça soixante 60 70
degrés pour être assez technique
aujourd'hui la compétition fait partie
du 3ème grade nationale après les
championnats de france et le championnat
régional 500 points était en jeu et un
arbitre officiel était présent pour la
régate pour remporter la victoire et
yoann à sa stratégie comme les skippers
professionnels aujourd'hui avant tout
peut tout à fait structurée donc
heureusement des fois ça
la porte s'ouvre pas où se refermer
fossé d'être actif regardez faut pas
regarder que son bateau faut regarder
beaucoup les autres pour pas faire
d'erreurs de placement
et puis pour essayer de regarder un
petit peu de surface du vent la surface
de la mer de briser ces eig une nouvelle
compétition de verser sera organisée
l'année prochaine sur les rives de l'ill
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
pour patienter jusque là les vagues de
la structure accueilleront les
championnats de flotte laser le 11
novembre prochain
mais cette fois ci en taille réelle